so you guys have been here for a few
months um and
uh
we just want to kind of talk about what
the plans were for you guys and what you
were thinking in terms of
um
moving out
is here kicking us out is what you're
saying
so we talked about before miona came
that
you could stay with us for a few months
we all had talked about
the end of the year
after you guys got married no no you
said to the end of the year so that's
another whole full month
so that's what we're talking about we
want to firm up plans
so you're getting married soon some
somewhere where where's that
i don't know yeah um you're getting
married sometime
soon
so when is that
we don't know yet no okay so that's
where we want to kind of figure out
that that's why we need to done just a
little bit more time just to figure it
out
[Music]
my parents are on some bullet
they're just um
not trying to help out they're not
supportive they're i don't
i just not what i expected
it seems like you're just trying to kick
us out so what's the
so again this goes back to plans this
isn't personal this isn't about not
wanting to be there we've said over and
over and over that we want to be at your
wedding
and we needed to know when so that we
could make plans yeah but we didn't know
when this k1 fiance visa was going to
come through we got
we got the interview date a week before
and the end of the summer so we didn't
have time to even plan anything
we didn't have 10 months to planning
okay so you had three months to plan
something and we're still in those three
months so it's right so i don't want to
argue about that
because
jabrie i know but that's that's if you
think about it it's kind of like
slap in the face a little bit
nope it's not a slap in the face
you
had plenty of time
before miona came
to look for places to get married
because you knew this was going to
happen eventually
we are following up with the plans
for you two
to
be on your own starting a married life
in your own place
at the end of the 90 days
[Music]
you